[Applause]
you turn 18 in november
november 1st are you gonna be able to
vote in november
yeah but i ain't gonna lie bro
bro i might sound crazy for him
but you i think
kanye was down there the best candidate
out of these two [ __ ]
you think kanye's the best candidate out
of joe and trump
what i mean for when he don't count
joe and trump
it's just some bad though i'm not gonna
lie to you it is probably the
worst selection of candidates we've ever
had
the worst in the world it's it's um like
you know they usually say like the less
of two evils right
but it i don't think it's ever been more
true than it is right now
yeah it's it's scary right now but
it's really scary but i for sure would
have went with kanye
over both of them oh great listen
i love kanye but uh
i'm gonna just i'm gonna just uh i'm
gonna hold my nose look the other way
you gotta think though i'm just trying
to get trump up out of there you feel me
he ain't gonna be making all the
decisions by himself
kanye the president don't make all the
decisions i feel you but i don't know
he gonna have a lot of people around him
but you know the lady who
who's gonna be his vice president is
like an insane
lady from wyoming who's like a
spiritual healer i don't know man it's i
don't know it's it's some real
shout out to kanye's my favorite artist
ever do i
any kanye art anywhere anyway uh i wanna
have spiritual years i wanna talk to him
i wanna speak